[Music]
on this Sunday night capsized off
California's Coast the migrant deaths
this is part of a transnational criminal
organization effort in what officials
say is among the worst smuggling
tragedies in the state's history
Flair frustrations passengers demand
payment after the airline's plane
seizures
Canada's bail backlash we need Common
Sense bail reform the political pressure
to tighten rules for violent offenders I
struggled a lot how a Canadian director
this happened already dips into her own
childhood in this oscar-nominated
feature
global national
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us a
tragedy is unfolding off the coast of
California at least eight people are
dead after the boat they were in
capsized near a San Diego beach
authorities believe it's part of a human
smuggling operation police say they
responded to a 9-1-1 call late last
night the caller a woman speaking
Spanish said she and other passengers of
a small fishing boat had made it to
shore but a second one had capsized
attempts by lifeguards to reach the
beach were hampered by high tide and
heavy fog two boats were located but no
survivors were found authorities say
it's one of the worst smuggling
tragedies in California's history
is not necessarily
people trying to find a better life this
is part of a transnational criminal
organization effort to smuggle people
into the United States these people are
often labor trafficked and sick
trafficked when they arrive
Crews pulled the bodies of eight adults
from the water their nationalities are
not yet known police believe some
passengers could have escaped on the
beach
to a developing drama unfolding at one
of Canada's low-cost air carriers Flair
Airlines is promising ticket holders
they will either fly on its own planes
or those of another airline at Flair's
expense that's after four of the
carrier's leased aircraft were seized
yesterday in what Flair is calling a
commercial dispute Global's Nathaniel
Dove reports no no definitely not never
it's not worth it two passengers on if
they'll ever take Flair Airlines again
they said that they would not offer a
hotel voucher because the flight was
canceled for our safety
and so when that happens they're not
responsible to give us a voucher Sadie
Vanier was on her way to Palm Springs to
see her family for March break but on
the same day four a flares aircraft were
seized causing cancellations a source
telling Global News Flair was five days
late on a million dollar payment to the
plane lender Vanier says they don't know
if they'll get compensation law does not
permit Airlines to act this way
passenger rights Advocate Gabor lukach
says Canadian laws Force Airlines to
help passengers with hotels and
compensation depending on the
circumstances but the regulations are
toothless what can what passengers need
to demand the members of parliament
support change to the regime change to
the to the air passenger protection
regulations in a statement to Global
News Flair said it will continue to fly
its schedule and it says we have
rebooked passenger flights with flair or
another airline at no additional cost
and customers can rebook their own
travel and receive an investment within
seven days Vanier says she received a
hotel voucher too late to use it and
hasn't heard back about compensation
for me I want more competition I don't
want the market has been governed by two
big monsters Air Canada and invested
Flair passenger Xiao Yu Tui just landed
in Saskatoon when he spoke to Global
News in January Air Canada canceled
flights from Saskatoon and Regina to
Calgary leaving only WestJet to fly that
route he's worried fewer Airlines means
more expensive tickets I wish a fair
Airline a best luck
in the future
Nathaniel Dove Global News Saskatoon
prime minister Justin Trudeau has been
under pressure to change the rules
surrounding the criminal code to update
Canada's bail system and address
challenges posed by repeat violent
offenders it's in the wake of the
killing of an Ontario Provincial Police
Officer last fall the accused in that
case was out on bail at the time of the
murder on Friday Federal Justice
Minister David lametti promised to make
targeted reforms but as David Aiken
reports there's been little detail about
the changes
the man accused of killing Ontario
Provincial Police Officer Gregory
perschela last December was out on bail
even though he was a repeat violent
offender
Rochelle's death quickly prompted calls
from politicians and police to tighten
bail rules we need Common Sense bail
reform
that says that multiple repeat violent
offenders who are newly arrested should
stay behind bars until their trial on
Friday Federal and provincial Justice
and Public Safety ministers agreed to
make changes to Canada's bail system the
reforms will address the challenges
posed by repeat violent offenders as
well as offenses committed involving the
use of firearms and other weapons such
as knives and bear spray and while
details will be released later the
federal government is being asked to
make the reverse onus provision apply to
anyone charged with the weapons offense
what that would mean is the onus would
be on the accused to prove they could be
safely released rather than leave the
onus on the state to prove the person
should stay in jail yet some bail reform
Advocates argue Public Safety would be
improved with more liberal bail rules
rules that kept more accused persons out
of jail when we look at the cost both in
dollars and cents the the social cost
the fact that when you detain someone in
custody it actually makes it more likely
that they'll commit an offense while
released Advocates say more bail
monitors more structured bail foreign
accused would better improve Public
Safety the solution is not incarcerating
more people there is a real cost there
that no one seems willing to talk about
the political momentum though seems to
be clearly moving in the direction of
tighter bail rules every single Premier
in the country for the first time is
unanimous on that point David Akin
Global News
Ottawa
the UK is being gripped by a controversy
involving some of the most hotly debated
topics in its Society immigration media
freedom and soccer Britain's National
broadcaster BBC has seen a series of TV
and radio hosts boycott the network over
the suspension of its highest paid
personality former Soccer Star Gary
lineker Redmond Shannon explains
Gary lineker is in the eye of a media
and political storm I'm gonna do my
shopping said would you mind letting me
do it on my own the former Soccer Star
is the highest paid host at the world's
largest broadcaster the BBC the face of
match of the day Britain's soccer
equivalent of Hockey Night in Canada
lineker is currently on the bench for
his reaction to the British government's
new immigration policy aimed at cracking
down on undocumented migrants enough is
enough we must stop the boats in
response to that video lineker tweeted
that the government uses language that
is not dissimilar to that used by
Germany in the 30s
invoking the Nazis sparked outrage among
many governing conservatives then the
BBC said lineker breached its guidelines
on political opinions suspending him
until an agreement is reached on his
social media use over the weekend
lineker's co-hosts analysts and
announcers boycotted soccer coverage and
solidarity with him leaving gaping holes
in BBC schedules and raising questions
about political interference at the
public service broadcaster we're Fierce
champions of democratic debate Free
Speech but with that comes the need to
create an impartial organization one
perception problem for the BBC is that
two of its top bosses are former Tories
one under investigation for helping
facilitate a million dollar loan for
former prime minister Boris Johnson it
looks slightly strange for them to be
um taking a tweet by he's someone who
after all isn't involved in their
politics and current affairs coverage
quite so seriously in the past other BBC
figures outside of news have made
political statements but have not faced
sanction lineker who has housed refugees
in his own home may not back down easily
Redmond Shannon Global News London
now to the Deluge down under Australia's
far north is dealing with
record-breaking flooding tonight and
officials are warning locals to stay out
of the rising water which is likely
infested with crocodiles even bull
sharks this is Burke town a tiny
community in Queensland completely cut
off to the outside world most of the
town's 160 residents have been airlifted
out by helicopter there's water as far
as the eye can see and the swollen
Albert River still hasn't reached its
flood Peak the region has been swamped
by an unprecedented wet season dropping
constant rain since December and
torrential downpours in the past week
emerging evidence on the dangers of
alcohol coming up why despite it most
Canadians aren't changing their drinking
habits
Canadians recently got some new guidance
about healthy alcohol consumption
advising everyone to reduce their intake
exclusive polling done for global news
shows younger Canadians are drinking
less alcohol but it also reveals most
Canadians are not prepared to cut back
tonight Catherine Ward unpacks the data
and looks at the dangers associated with
drinking alcohol
we are seeing a shift in alcohol
consumption in Canada and it's being
driven by that younger Generations the
data on drinking
is showing an increasing distinction by
age
it seems that younger Canadians uh are
more uh concerned about the level of
alcohol they consume 40 of Canadians say
they have cut back their drinking since
the New Year according to exclusive
polling by ipsos for Global News among
people age 18 to 34 that number jumps to
51 percent overall 18 percent of people
say they have participated in a dry
month and again that number jumps when
you zero in on the younger age bracket
to 31 percent what we're seeing in that
data is consistent with what we often
see in terms of human behavior
behavioral scientists say people often
put a lot of emphasis on their
individual experience when it comes to
modifying their choices
if I'm 50 55 and I've perhaps had a few
more years of recreational enjoyment of
beverages under my belt and haven't
experienced any ill health effects that
I'm aware of then I'm much less likely
to be convinced or swayed by emerging
evidence because my individual
experience suggests that this isn't as
much of a risk for me
younger Canadians are more concerned
about the level of alcohol they consume
they're more likely to be taking steps
to reduce their consumption more likely
to believe that alcohol consumption is
linked to both their physical and their
Mental Health
still change is slow the polling shows
across the board roughly three quarters
of people say it's unlikely their
alcohol intake will change in light of
the new guidelines much more work to be
done Beyond just updating the guidelines
and hoping that the behaviors will
follow suit
experts say many people choose to change
behaviors at the start of a new year so
the real test will be to see if these
numbers hold through the coming months
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
right had mixed about the market experts
weigh in on Canada's spring housing
Outlook
[Music]
Canadians overwhelmed by Rising costs
got a bit of a reprieve last week on
Wednesday the Bank of Canada hit pause
on interest rate hikes for the first
time in nearly a year although it's
leaving the door open for more hikes in
the near future as Ann gaviola explains
experts are divided on the impact
there are signs we could see housing
activity pick up steam this spring even
though the number of homes selling
remains significantly lower than last
year the market did slow in December
January and has picked up in February
we've seen volumes increasing from coast
to coast the CEO of Royal LePage is
optimistic about the spring Market
people will feel comfortable that
interest rates aren't going to depress
home prices in the future in other words
we've reached the bottom of the cycle
and it's uphill from here but not
everyone sees it that way a new report
from RBC Economist Robert Hogue suggests
activity will hit bottom sometime this
spring and prices will level out a few
months later if the Bank of Canada is
done raising interest rates the forecast
a 15 decline in National home prices
with roughly half of that still to come
some of the biggest price Corrections
are expected in Ontario this year
Bancroft Northumberland Hills and
Woodstock Ingersoll topped the list with
expected declines ranging from 40 to 50
percent that's according to new research
from Desjardins it expects a 20
correction for the greater Toronto area
which is not what Toronto realtor
pratesh parekh sees in the cards I'm
expecting a boom if I had to guess right
now based on the fact that February has
been picking up week after week plus the
supply has been relatively low low
Supply in Toronto has already spurred
the return of competition among buyers
bidding wars I'm definitely starting to
see more of those come back right now
the ultimate question is is this going
to be a blip for season and then do we
go back to a little bit of slowness
again or is this the bottom has passed
and we are continuing to go up from here
the wild card is what the Bank of Canada
will do when it comes to interest rates
the Central Bank announced a conditional
pause Wednesday and it reserves the
right to start hiking again if needed
and gaviola Global News Toronto
there are still concerns for many
Canadians who can't afford a home but in
2020 the federal government invested
billions in a rapid housing project
aimed at helping them in its initial
stages more than ten thousand affordable
housing units were approved across
Canada to be built within 12 to 18
months yet as of November less than 1500
are completed Alicia drows has more on
the initiative's challenges
in April 2021 an old schoolhouse in
Halifax was demolished to make room for
more affordable housing now it's been
transformed to Sunflower Court home to
nearly 50 women and kids we have friends
that are
you know full like that are truly
affordable it's 30 of a household's
income for most here rent is under 350
that means that
um individuals and families who were
previously homeless and housing insecure
have a secure beautiful place to live
the project was part of the federal
rapid Housing Initiative aimed at
quickly providing new affordable housing
units for those most in need but
projects haven't all been quick even
Sunflower Court a success story was
still five months overdue we were
building during like early coveted times
and so I think it's no surprise that we
encountered lots of additional
challenges related to you know supply
chain and cost and also labor shortages
round one approved more than 4 700 units
the majority were meant to be completed
by March 2022 but as of November just
over a quarter were done we should be
very concerned because in the end this
is for individuals who are suffering
right now even when completed the 10 000
new affordable units are just a drop in
the bucket according to the 2021 census
nearly 21 of households are spending
more than 30 percent of their income on
housing that's less than in 2016 but it
means over 8 million Canadians live in
unaffordable housing situations the
rapid Housing Initiative is significant
it was set the stage and now we I think
we need to really really kind of develop
much more along those lines the
organization behind Sunflower Court says
they're ready to build more it's just
about getting the money we would like to
see much more investment in public and
social housing and non-profit run
housing Alicia drives Global News
Halifax
[Music]
next a look at some of the standout
Talent at the at these curves
[Music]
it is Hollywood's biggest night as the
Academy Awards are set to kick off among
the Canadians nominated for an Oscar
tonight one animator from Pixar is
standing out director Domi she's turning
red received wide praise last year for
its hilarious and heartwarming story of
a Toronto teen turned giant red panda
with a nod for best animated feature
she's also brought a unique Asian
Canadian perspective to the world stage
Farah Nasser has more
from excitement over your favorite boy
bands concert to doing homework on a TTC
streetcar Pixar's oscar-nominated
turning red earnestly captures the
teenage experience in early 2000s
Toronto with one important catch
[Music]
this happened already Canadian director
Domi she first started at Pixar as an
intern 12 years ago
she later won over hearts and an Academy
Award for her animated short bow today
at 33 years old she is now a vice
president at the company and the first
woman to direct a full-length Pixar
feature this story is anything but
classic while navigating Life as a teen
13 year old May magically transforms
into a giant red panda
[Music]
o m g exploring the pressures of growing
up in a family of Asian Canadian
immigrants turning Reds inspired by xi's
own Coming of Age experience that she
believes many others have related to I
struggled a lot with being you know like
on one hand my mom's perfect little
daughter and on the other hand embracing
this wild
emotional passionate side of myself that
I was turning into that was taking me
away from from my mom and my culture
it's a big reason she set the film in
the very City she grew up in in the
diverse Multicultural backdrop of
Toronto she found support from other
immigrant kids who knew what she was
going through important bonds that are
also seen through May's loyal friends I
never felt like the token Asian or I
never felt othered for my asian-ness I
mean I felt others for being a huge nerd
another important goal for she to show
the vibrant side of Canada most
International audiences may not be
familiar with like when they think of
Canada they think of snow and
Lumberjacks and moose making this movie
was an opportunity for me to show them
the Canada that I know that I love she
isn't the only Canadian up for this
year's best animated feature fellow
Ontarian and Veteran Disney animator
Chris Williams has also been nominated
for his Netflix film The Sea Beast
the flying sailor a Canadian short about
the Halifax Explosion is also up for
best animated short film displaying the
ongoing success of Canadian perspectives
in Hollywood and the animation industry
I think we like see the world in this in
the slightly different way and we
observe things in a slightly different
way than Americans and I think that's
what makes our storytelling and our
sense of humor kind of unique a sense of
community a sense that people are going
to look out for each other so I think
that there is something in sort of the
Canadian psyche I suppose that lends
itself towards animation in that way
and with this year's
years we're an Asian
category May's love for boy bands while
navigating the unexpected ups and downs
of Heritage feels right at home far
enough sir Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Nita Garcia tonight's
Air Canada is a misty morning in
Saskatoon we love seeing your Canada
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching Donna will be back with you
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]